التوجه الاوروبيه وغربي الجديد يهدف
لتوطيد العلاقات مع الصين في مجالات
الاستراتيجيه مهمه التقارب الغربي
صاحباتهم وحاولات لتحييد الصين عن روسيا
وتصحيح مسار العلاقات مع واشنطن وبعد نقطه
انطلاق جديده فخصوم الامس يسعون اليوم
لفتح صفحه جديده والهدف تجنب النزاعات
المستقبليه وفتح باب التعاون الاستراتيجي
المشترك ضمن خطه تذيب جليد خلافات عميقه
طال عمرها اليوم حدت الخلافات بين واشنطن
وبكين تراجعت بعد ما اكد رئيس بانه سيسعى
قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع الصين والتي يمكن
ان تلعب دورا فعالا في حل الازمه الروسيه
الاكرميه الدوره ايضا على فرنسا حيث دعى
الرئيس الفرنسي عن ريال ماكرون نظره
الصيني الى ضروره جلب روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات لايجاد حل للحرب في اوكرانيا
وتجنب التصعيد فتوحيد الجهود الدو
للاستجابه للازمات العالميه بين بكين
والغرب باتضروريه خصوصا وان العالم يمر في
مرحله من الاضطرابات والتحولات التي تحتاج
الى الانفتاح والتعاون وفق صحيفه رموز
الفرنسي
[موسيقى]
يمنحني اجتماع اليوم الفرصه للتعبير عن
اراده لاعطاء دفعه جديده لتجديد تعاوننا
والانضمام الى بعضنا من اجل مواجهه
التحديات الدوليه الكبيره
تتمحور اساسا حول انشطه الصين يسعى الغرب
لتجاوزها بالتسويه الوديه لانه بيتعلم
جيدا بان الصين تعتبر لاعب اساسي في
الاقتصاد العالمي وباعتبارها طبعا ثاني
اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وبالتالي فان فتح
مجال التعاون معها وتوسيع الاستثمارات
سيعود على اوروبا بالفائده ووفق تقرير
صادر عن مجله
فان الصين استثمرت ما يصل الى 20 مليار
دولار في الموانئ الاجنبيه بين عام 2010 و
2020 وهنا نعود لزياره المستشار الالمانيه
الاخيره الى الصين والتي اعادت للواجهها
دوافع القرار الالماني بخصوص السماح لشركه
لشركه صينيه بشراء حصه تبلغ نحو 25% من
مرفارج الذي يعاد اكبر موانئ البلاد وهو
ما زاد طبعا المحاوف الامريكيه من تمدد
بكين بشبكه موسعه في موانع اجنبيه خصوصا
وان معظم الصفقات الصينيه تستهدف السيطره
على قطاعات من البنيه التحتيه الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]